It's called GRE / SAT Vocab Lock.
This is an Android app and it's available in the Google Play Store...
...that lets you learn a new word every time you unlock your phone.
A normal person will unlock their smartphone over 100 times a day.
That's a lot!
So what if you could use that time to learn a new vocabulary word?
This app will make you learn up to 20 different words a day.
You will receive a word and you have to drag it over to its synonym.
If you get it right, it turns green and if you get it wrong, it turns red.
If you don't have a clue,...
...you can drag the word to the little "d," which stands for "define."
GRE / SAT Vocab Lock will repeat the same word...
...until the app feels that you've learned that word.
Today, I learned the word "sanguine," which means "cheerfully optimistic" or "happy."